so I think I'm going to have to hope a
few holes in some of the
ization they came before us because from
my point of view as a student and I
think dick will probably concur all of
this development seems very logical very
organized that way was presented this
morning I think our student experience
was something less than very logical and
very organized I mean we were an
undefined profession in a totally
unstructured environment the NCC PA did
not exist the aapa existed but so did
three other organizations they had not
yet merged into one there was no
enabling legislation there was no way to
get credentialed in the hospital there
was no way to do anything we didn't know
who we were and it was very difficult to
tell other people who we were because we
didn't know either all those professors
that they talked to about teaching us I
would say the first five to ten minutes
of every class was spent explaining why
we needed to know what it was they were
supposed to be teaching us there were
some of the surgeons that thought we
really needed to know very fine details
surgical anatomy so that we could
anticipate the instruments they would
need at any stage of an operation so
that in our minds you know back then
that people refer to the type a but I
don't know if a lot of you know there
was a Type B in a Type C and a lot of
the surgeons here thought that we were
going to be super Oh architects we
clearly had other ideas they didn't
always get well received by some of the
professor's we talked to who attempted
to teach us what they thought we should
know so it was a pretty chaotic time I
mean actually having just taken me into
CPA for the sixth or seventh Sarah
whatever time I'm surprised that we
ended up with a foundation of knowledge
that has enabled us to continue to
practice clinically all these years so
it was kind of crazy I think however
that that undefined pneus allowed some
of us the absolute privilege of putting
what we thought should be what this
profession was all about we were not
going to be content
be mindless robots technicians we were
thinking decision-making differential
diagnostic kinds of professionals and it
took a long time to get that through a
lot of places there was no organization
there was no student organization and I
think that some of us realized that if
we were ever going to grow and function
into what we thought we should become
that a lot of our energy was devoted to
structure I mean dick and I sort of
elected each other as the founding
president and secretary of the jack
whole society because when Bruce's class
started they were finally enough of us
to be able to have all the right
officers because there weren't enough of
us to do that and it burley became
apparent that that if we provided the
structure for the organization from
within rather than from without it would
become what we wanted it to be I think
one of my fondest memories in getting
the Connecticut having a physician
assistants organized is there are a lot
of us and we were the new health
professionals we were physician
assistants we were we weren't even sure
who we were back then and we finally had
this set of bylaws and it came time to
vote on it and we realized that we
didn't know how to tell who had the
right to vote because we had a series of
different people and at that point there
were some nurse practitioners that were
kind of hanging with us and could we
create one organization in Connecticut
like a couple of other states
successfully did we were not successful
at doing that it ended up with a scizzum
and and just became physician assistants
but that undefined nature was something
that followed us through through
everything I mean when I was hired I
chose to stay at yale-new Haven Hospital
when I graduated because one of the
things that I sadly missed as a student
was a role model of what I'm supposed to
look like
that was pretty hard in 1971 I mean we
had a PA in the program but he was an
administrator so you know I didn't want
to do what he was doing so you didn't
have that clinical role model so I chose
to stay at Yale for 10 years and it was
like okay you can work here what are you
supposed to do try to get credentialed
at an Ivy League hospital when their
credentialing holes around and your
title is square and by the way for the
state of Connecticut I'm in formally
trained because the program was not
accredited when I was a student so the
state of Connecticut doesn't recognize
the fact that you know I spent two years
at the Y school Bruce is also informally
trained after that those people they all
went to school we just didn't that's
what I think one of the things that
sticks out in my mind story time is I
was on call I was actually at a meeting
at the department chairs house we were
talking about a new protocol every
position i worked with was there but I
was the one on call somebody got sick
they needed antibiotics I went in you
know saw the patient did my thing wrote
the orders went back to the meeting the
next day the evening nurse came up to me
in tears and said she couldn't talk to
me anymore we couldn't be friends
anymore because the nursing supervisor
had told her that if she ever followed
another one of my order she would get
fired so that very nice thing about
supervision Direction delegation was so
undefined that it left an incredible
amount of room you could define
supervision is over the shoulder you
could define supervision as
telecommunications and depending upon
what you thought about what these
upstart people that were running around
maybe killing people were that that
initial legislation left so much room
for your own interpretation of what it
was that it was a source of life of
comfort
I think I'll stop my dick say something
cuz I can go on I'm a little bit
different tracked here perhaps some for
my heart I like to thank so much that
that we're all being still damaged I'll
sit here and Yale for coming through I
mean it was chaotic it was changing day
to day people didn't know who we were
including the people that were
instructing us we didn't know who we
were and yet at the end of that time I
felt that I had the most intense I never
intends the event in my life certainly
the most stimulating I never worked so
hard but enjoyed it so much before or
after I felt and learned that I was
prepared as much as one can be I had an
excellent foundation and then of course
my learning went on as when you leave
school if they're students here you're
just beginning to learn but again I
thank you was that a love or was that a
dub I'm not sure I thank you for
continuing this profession and and
helping support and it's remarkable that
now at 40 years were still and expanded
so much and those early struggles were
not in vain by many of you and those
those who were so insightful in seeing
what the potential was and holdin to it
against some very very strong
permanent fixed things and it's even
especially in an institution like this
where things tend to be fixed and
remarkable anyway I just kind of like
then instead kind of move more toward
anecdotal kinds of things that that that
help but maybe help you understand what
we as new pas way back experienced one
of the things of course is my great fear
is that I would i SPECT i came across
the country from montana direct to Yale
I came from an Indian Reservation where
I was working at the time talk about
culture shock but then I spent too
intense years here but then there was
always is somebody as a patient going to
see me are they going to listen to me am
I going to really be able to use this
wonderful training so I have a couple
anecdotal things that I might kind of
throw out dr. Sattar talked about Jess
code we were strictly knowledge yes been
polishing and at that time and I don't
know where it is now but medical
students in the same institution did not
have a strict dress code to say the
least so in our learning many times we
were with interns medical students we
made rounds with everybody and we would
hopefully find the best teacher follow
them in this group of sometimes 20
people run into a room the patient is
laying there somebody had present the
patient to the to everyone everybody had
talked about this in this and in almost
always the professor had the white coat
well we certainly had our white coat
okay and then there were of the other 20
people there there were
various forms of dress so in this
particular patient I remember patience
laying there and looking at all the all
that and people are talking and pulling
up things in and she's like this and at
the end of that time the professor says
do you have any questions says yes I
know you're a doctor and I know you're a
doctor but who in the heck are the rest
of these people and to the two students
appearance is important it's important
people make judgments of that they're
scared they're they're afraid they need
people to help guide them and they're
looking to see where that is going to
come from and part of that is visual so
students try to remember that one early
in clinical rotations after the didactic
section we had of course rotations for
periods of time with different entities
I believe this was a surgical rotation
and I was attached to one of the
surgeons and we were called to the
emergency room here in Yale New Haven
came into the emergency room and to the
suite where they were and it was chaos
and you could see blood on the floor and
I could see tennis shoes and there was a
young person who had an obvious tibial
fracture which was open bones were
present and they were at if you've been
in the emergency room you know that
things are going trying to help this
patient and so somebody's hanging up
this some of the others already know
over here somebody's yelling out orders
somebody's checking is hanging the IV it
so on thought so I'm there and I'm just
on that first few days with the surgeon
and and he's he takes a look and it
takes charge and he starts he starts
bark
out orders to everyone and has been done
and then it was there and they were
preparing to take the patient to the o.r
for repair at this time he turns around
quickly and bumps into me because I
learned that I have to stay real close
and that's where you know and try to
catch what information that you can and
as you go along and you write it down
and then go back and learn it okay and
then I'm new to this whole thing so he
turned 3 out of bumps into me almost and
he looked startled and he looks at my
nametag as he didn't even know me yet he
said Paul go assess that patient and
partly he was saying get out of my way
I'm trying to get this all done you know
do something so you know so I go over
and I think okay by training what do i
do assessment airway okay breathing
circulation so I'm doing this okay 90
second exam quick exam head to toe so
I'm looking looking at eyes getting
clothes smelling because this is what I
was trained to do I'm running my hands
over the patient okay and I'm looking
okay and as I come around behind the
skull it's soft and I think no it's not
supposed to be soft and I look at my
fingers and it's red another clue okay
this is before universal precautions
and it and then I follow the protocol I
continued my exam going on down moving
but the quick exam that it a stethoscope
Lucinda chest level but and now I'm
elbowing my way through all kinds of
other interns and nurses of trying to
help this patient so I work my way down
I finish it quickly I go over and and
the surgeons is back to me and he's
doing one of these when I go you know he
looks at me in then he says what and i
say i think the patients has it has a
depressed skull fracture oh you mean so
he walks over and then i should I show
him and then he of course changes he
starts yelling out new sets of orders
and obviously the priorities are
changing here we've got an emergent
problem that must be addressed right
away and so and as things turned out
patient was sent to the o.r soon right
after imaging and and patient survived
and did well the leg was taken care of
later okay but the I guess the point
hero at the end of this situation then
patient was out of the room and and
everybody is kind of tidying up just a
little bit and the surgeon kind of makes
us stern face and then he says everybody
stop I'm thinking oh my god I've done
something and he says listen this
patient was here for 35 minutes we were
working on everything but the primary
problem the patient was not properly
assessed I have a student who is AP a
student who came assess it and in 60
seconds came to me with a new problem
this will not happen again and he went
on and of course I'm stringing down
and I'm getting looks from everyone else
but I guess the point is I didn't didn't
know how to cut corners yet I had good
training I knew what to do I followed my
protocol and my learning and perhaps
help the patient so again thanks to Yale
for that I think you've heard a little I
think you've heard a little bit today
about how being in the right place at
the right time can do something I i need
to you know share a story of something
that happened to me and if I go on about
how undefined and how chaotic things
were then let me also say it totally
added to the fun and given what I know
now if I could start over again I would
have sort of gotten it much faster
because I had a much better image in my
mind so so for me being part of a new
profession was just an incredible amount
of fun and those professional
organizations provided a training ground
so as I ended up in hospital management
later on in my career the mistakes and
managing I made when I was a volunteer
it's a lot covered in two by fire a
volunteer so that some of us did our
management training within the aapa or
canapa or one of those PA organizations
so that when we did it for real in a
paid position we were much more
effective than we would have been if we
hadn't have had that background I was a
second-year student it was in may of May
June of my second year and the rotation
I was on was ending on Friday and I
didn't know where I was going and I went
to the executive directors office and
said Paul where am I going on Monday he
said uh there might be a problem with
that I'll tell you later Paul three
o'clock on friday afternoon when are you
going to tell me uh let me make a phone
call come back in about half an hour
maybe you should take monday off I knew
this was a problem they never gave us
any
the only time off we had during our
academic year was one of our classmates
got married so we had a week off so he
could go back to Iowa and get married
and that was our spring break but I was
supposed to go on internal medicine
rotation starting on Monday morning and
sometime late the week before this local
small Hospital which needs to remain
nameless decided that they were not
ready to allow in their institution
someone who could come in and kill other
patients they were very leery of what
was going to happen and they just
decided they were not ready to join this
experiment and be part of what was
happening fortunately the executive
directors wife was the administrative
assistant of a local university
department she said with her chairman
out of town it's ok we'll take Burdine
now the chairman didn't know that she
said that so I have this program
placement rotation we have a lot of
those in medical oncology starting on
Monday the problem was that someone who
knew I was doing it ran into the
Chairman before she got to tell him that
they had offered to take a pee a student
serendipitous for me I spent the next 38
years in medical oncology so you know
it's one of those good things that may
have not happened for a good reason but
clearly led me into what became my life
work clinically and one of the things
that I would like to do if you don't
want whatever is is I know I know people
didn't have time for any questions of
Fred Blair and an but if there's
anything that we can relate if people
have questions about specific acts
aspects of what it was like to be where
we were when we were there some
weren't very far behind us but about the
way things changed or how we managed to
do some things I mean I think that we
would be more than happy to take
questions yes bird since we're doing
memories of the past sheriff take a
moment to reflect on all of those non
physicians who are part of our
environment our teaching environment who
were actually the ones that are really
responsible for teaching us our craft
teaching of Medicine in particular like
the Kremlin she was nothing or not
absolutely the rest of the research
assistants physiology the pharmd is in
the pharmacy we're all trying to develop
their own expertise within the health
field who actually taught us far more
and far earlier than either position or
other PA crowd you know that what that
whole team thing goes back to what we
are as pas that we are a member of a
team we are not a separate entity and
this was addressed in a number of so
that I am assistant an associate but
primarily for the patient and all of
those instructors and helpful people of
various levels that helped me become a
better PA I then had in my brain when I
went out into real life and then I would
I could reach out and that physical
physical therapy taught me so much that
those therapists that let's say and so I
was able to reach out and say hey the
physical therapy can be a part of the
help for this patient nursing can be the
psychologist the etc etc etc can be so
helpful the radiation the radiation
technologists they have information
they've studied you can use that to help
your patient so we are a part of that
huge team and
if you students can use that and not
think of you know it's just me and the
physician then you're you're missing out
the next chapter was it probably took
four years to get back to what had
happened before that there was a change
in nursing leadership at yale-new Haven
Hospital with a chief nursing officer
who absolutely believed there was no
role in any institution for pas actually
she went so far as she told my sister
who was the nursing administrator at the
time to go home and tell me that I
needed to find something else to do with
my life and it took oh it probably took
that was probably a year or two after I
graduated it probably took six or seven
years before you could then you know
comfortably write orders and it depended
upon where you were and that was that
was one of the things that was so
interesting about the profession Jeff
and Bruce are running around plastic
surgery doing what they needed to do
taking care of patients everything was
wonderful and over on medicine up four
flights and around the corner the world
was totally different so the
inconsistency until there was hard and
fast regulations that said you must you
should it was difficult to cope with the
tons but I think they probably took five
years
five years behind you and Charlie are
all those people it is drugs drugs
actually yo you saying the absolute
belief you know when you're 22 years old
people you believe and I came out of the
60s you know so i believe that i could
make this work along that along the same
lines I what I left Yale went into a
rural practice in the middle of Iowa we
had a small town of 900 people my
physicians opened up several satellite
clinics I was there all the time there
were two docs who came in two half days
a week the rest of time it was me the
communications were I looked at it very
closely to make sure that there was
going to be communications 24 hours a
day even though it was by phone and I
was scared to death but partly as I said
earlier I was afraid is anybody going to
come and see me so small story I have
been there maybe a year was seeing a
patient knock on the door the nurse said
you have a long distance call and it's
important I said okay so I came up hello
this is mr. Smith at the other end of
the line who was a farmer who spent his
winters in Arizona from Iowa
and he says I i I'm in trouble I had
some chest pain and some shortness of
breath and they took me to the hospital
and they did some tests and then they
said that they needed to operate on me
and I said okay he says I'm afraid and I
said okay did the doctors talk to you
about it yes do you know what they're
going to do yes do they do you feel that
you have trust yes are you in pain and
so on and so I'm trying to reassure him
and I'm hearing in the background as I'm
talking to him male voices shouting and
I and I eventually I say well who is
that that's the surgeon they want to
take me to the operating room but I want
I needed to call you to see if it was
okay he had to get an okay from five
states away from his PA that it was okay
to go to the operating room now
basically it says that yeah we said that
that my heart was still beating that
that that we he trusted me and that he
was that to me an exaggerated extreme
but that that was you know one of those
things in life that you feel okay maybe
I'm doing the right thing maybe I chose
to do the right thing and maybe people
will come to see me well
discovering a similar model I think it's
great now you know that we had trouble
going to hospitals seven miles away now
students are doing rotations in
countries 7,000 miles away the world
clearly is a different place than it was
40 years ago the acceptance that the
profession is a different place but you
know I think I think the works not done
I still think there's a lot of work to
do I was at Yale when that selex report
was going on we were really worried that
the program was not going to continue
and for a little while at some of those
meetings I had kind of an insider one of
the dots from the community that was on
it was a good buddy so I you know would
kind of get a little feedback and things
didn't look good at some of those
meetings for us you know so I'm really
happy to see that the university has now
embraced the program to the extent that
it has which means to me the university
is now behind the profession in a way
that it was what it wasn't in the early
days I mean it was but not with the
emotion and the resources and the extent
that it is now I mean if you look at my
certificate there is not an official
University signature on it it's these
guys that's it was pretty quickly
there's the question you still have that
question sir yes yes good
I was a very young college graduate who
had fallen into the fact that I wanted
to be a member of the healing arts very
late in my collegiate career my first
destination was to be a math professor
and when I got into flipping planes in
space I realized this was not for me so
my bowl was patient care and as I
weighed my options in the spring of
nineteen seventy I fell literally over a
sign hanging on the first floor boardman
that was the trauma program with the
surgical associate program and at that
point started to investigate it I did
have patient care experience I had done
that summers during college but I was
different from the rest of my classmates
they did more the ex-military Peace
Corps kinds of things different kinds of
clinical experience so that was me and I
just want to take care of patients and I
was going to take the fastest route to
get me there and I looked at Medical
School I needed a couple prerequisites
that would have been another year and a
half but I wasn't really interested in
that anyway I looked at nursing school I
have nurses in the family I knew what
those frustrations worth professionals
decided I didn't want to do that and
frankly it was exciting being a pioneer
and being part of something new I'm and
I think I was partially drawn to I don't
know what this is going to be but I
think I'm going to do it I think it was
interesting that all five members of our
class came from completely different
kinds of backgrounds and they chose us I
don't know how because I I mean there
wasn't I could never see a pattern
what's hot I bet I can never see a
pattern as I look at each of us in and
sometimes I thought well how can they do
that without this background or or in
sofa but I mean everyone turned out to
be an excellent excellent provider and
so with their wisdom they were able to
do that I personally came from I was a
medic in the service in the army and
then after college at Ohio State my wife
and I hi Terry we decided we wanted to
try to do something maybe get back in
that time when you possibly can so we
joined vista which is the domestic Peace
Corps and we went through the Northern
Cheyenne Indian Reservation in Montana
and worked just present yourself in
whatever skills you have to help them do
what they need to do what they want to
do you do so I had medical background so
and I was in a village way away from and
this is rural Montana and so whatever
came along medically was pretty much me
because there was nothing there in our
village and so I was off on the phone
with the people at the docks at the
Indian Health Service and we had some
some pretty bad cases but you know I
tried to help what I could anyway at the
end of our time there the doc said look
you know you've got these skills you
certainly like to do it you like people
why don't you consider in a medical
school and I said well I never really
you know seriously thought about that
but I am 30 years old and he said well
it's about it let's look let's apply so
again serendipity his wife was a nurse
she had a nursing magazine in there was
a little article about their opening up
looking for students for the first class
at Yale for pas and I looked at that too
and I said well this might be something
good it might be a stepping stone it
might be another way to learn might be
another credential and so I applied the
joke was we had one phone in the village
okay at the church and so the joke was
they had to send an Indian runner to get
me to so when Yale called and said hey
you can come out
you know but anyway so that was
basically where I'm where I was coming
from I just wanted to say that I know
that we have one international guests
and we invited another individual
they're individuals from Africa and
China that will be joining us at
different times during the day to learn
a little bit more about our profession
they happen to be here visiting Yale for
other reasons and I wanted to invite
them for that you know apropos to the
conversation we'll take one more
question because I know we need to have
a bathroom break in lieu of the question
may I make a hole yes humorous event
that maybe i was called i was in my
clinic in iowa and there was i was
called to the scene where a farm life
had tried to end her life with taking
multiple pills the river rescue people
went she would refuse to do anything
except just sit there and die they
called me she was my patient I went to
the third farm on the right and and she
wouldn't let anybody else get near her
she allowed me to be near her we sat we
talked I had a bottle of ipecac in my
pocket you know and and keep looking at
my watch you know because time is is
working against this every minute
meanwhile a helicopter rescue helicopter
arrived most the farmers are here so
we've got a big crowd she says I
convince her that she will go she took
the ipecac I'm saying okay so I've got
my arm around her we come outside we are
going to transport her because she's
she's going to die with the with the
bill she had she sees the crowd gets
scared sits down in this farm yard okay
so I turn her around and we are sitting
there and I've got my arm around her and
we're just sitting in the grass in this
farm yard and try it because the crowd
was behind us the helicopter was behind
us and I think that was a scaring her
meanwhile I'm trying to convince her
meanwhile I'm hoping that she's going to
start to have some emesis so she indeed
does and she's throwing up and I and I
can see actual some of the medicine that
she had consumed fine things are going
well until about this time there's this
grunting noise oh oh and I don't know if
you've ever seen a full-grown hog they
can stand about this high they can be
about 600 pounds and this hog is
spelling the vomitus it is now I'm
trying to get this woman calm and here
is this this hog trying to get in
between our legs where she has vomited
okay it gets better along with your
she's got at least a half a dozen little
piglets which are squealing now the
mother is calling the piglets they're
coming from all directions they're going
in and out around our legs I am trying
to be cool but my I'm kicking with my
feet trying to keep the things away you
did not train me to handle
patient survived things went well but
there are numerous things out there
that's a great way to end